what's happening reject nation it's Greg
Alva here and it's John you didn't know
Ruggiero first or be issuing I didn't I
was just doing the thing that you're
doing I wasn't looking at you and you're
Lauren Frank are you Lauren Lauren
Shannon sorry we just like to make our
guests feel as comfortable as pop you
want your board we got our Lord we got
our Lord that's our second channels we
got our now what Lauren was telling me
that there's this trailer out for this
movie called bodied and Eminem produced
it and we just watched the video top 10
celebrity disses by Eminem Eminem so we
were like yeah let's watch this and then
John showed up as he does with Mike
Kramer I just walk away
matt'll wet is not toxic it's a street
by word our weapon we battle rap we
battled each other and disrespect each
other to bring it rap if you go off you
will let you feel my face say obscenely
racist things under guys I know how
sensitive Klein was to racism and for
which illustration is now under a lot of
pressure to act understand [ __ ] dad
[Music]
yo yo [ __ ] up will score me little
reddit blogger another Eminem imposter
refers to Elton John as a second father
Bob Saget Rick Moranis Kelly Osbourne
white-trash
genetic monster probably conceived in
the back of the Led Zeppelin concert at
Terry's Potter had sex with Jeffrey
Dahmer you'd be the lesbian daughter ah
prison [ __ ] rape victim the new face
of racism I'm surprised you didn't show
up here today with a slave with him
change him he hates african-american
culture cuz he was raised different he
hates couldn't say blinken pretty much
anybody that can relate with him except
Blake Griffin he feels a little bit more
safe with imposition attic same business
[ __ ] his heart was bent for minorities
it's never been for you sneaky asses
not affect what he's a little [ __ ]
reading whack and he needs me in English
classes and give me that [ __ ] Oh vases
and fragments and not you can take the
meek it has it now you get to complete
your dream of being this genius math
which is everything and fades in
fractions I can go [ __ ] out of your love
[ __ ] bleeding
Oh
[Music]
Wow
Dallas so cool now looks amazing awesome
oh man anybody caught fire on that dudes
water no no that was just happened to
him I want to know those like watching a
puppy being murdered five continuous
seconds that was sickly ridden man well
it's written
yeah they had two different angles one
the P will be the one common maybe they
had fair enough yeah I know way too to
camera unless they are really small yeah
great qualities I mean the way it's shot
looks really cool or since eight models
we've gotten some pretty awesome Ratliff
movies about rappers since Hustle & Flow
straight out of Compton as well as some
pretty good rap films I feel like when I
see that trailer it really looks like
they're doing something entirely
different with the rap movie genre a lot
of times when I see these rap movies
even though a lot of them are great they
all seem kind of similar
this seems back to what I love so much
about like a mile for example was the
raw grittiness of what freestyling is
what rap battling is and how important
that culture is it has this such weight
in the way everything is being
captivated here I mean I'm excited front
of that rap was that was dope you think
he's gonna come back little kid like you
come back and it could be a good rapper
what about my new glasses writing be
honest that means he takes the glasses
off declares that they are in fact fake
glasses
yeah then just destroy that he'd write
that bag wasn't really scared the whole
time yeah it wasn't Mach II didn't would
have to moralize by the histories he was
just luring him into his trap I feel
like when I watch people freestyle
sometimes were so mean I'm doing me
I probably be that white kid who was
freaking out you're so mean me I mean I
believe
that seemed being like wow your dick
yeah like good rhymes great you want
what do you want for what fashion closet
you want to recommence mess well I
didn't know the property damage was okay
you may get something that like Eminem
had to deal with like when he was like
starting to be robbed or do you think
that happened to him like someone did
that oh yeah his vision is terrible he
just wore off glasses from now I don't
know if that specifically happened to
him but I know he was definitely bullied
in the rap game I like watching movies
about people becoming successful rappers
and all that and doing them in the
writing but to me the freestyling world
is the most raw form of rap and this has
that rawness to oh yeah lottie's intense
yeah it does the main thing I took away
from this with intensity couldn't quite
tell what kind of movie this is supposed
to be and who's going to focus on but I
did get intensity and the rap game and
especially in an arena where you're only
as good as tonight's bars like that
feeling sunk in so yeah this is really
gripped me can you rap Lawrence so this
is the story oh well like you had that
plan the whole time
look at that feel like you did gonna
help with that yeah that was an awesome
trailer subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification build a John
Humphrey quit Instagram I want my Lauren
is Lauren Francesca Lauren Francesca is
I want my Lauren it's all one big time
Luke follow her on YouTube people and
patreon.com slash the real rejects is a
real website take care